oh man it's classless man we've just
signed the contract paid the money and
we're gonna go and have a save it so
driving in convoy with Samuel and Monday
got Anna and Emily in the back so yeah
exciting time
[Music]
yeah you probably want to obviously
change to the partitioning to make it
more modern day yeah but the time time
but at the same time keeping the
character I'm glad that it's it's good
I'm Asian absolutely humongous
it's an old castle with lot of history
and they're just about to get this
changed from for sale to salt so feeling
really excited massive project and gonna
be really really exciting
[Music]
so last week we went to an auction and
we had to walk away because someone went
over and this is about formulas not
feelings
however we then had a call back from the
agent saying that there were some
complications with the person that won
the bid and they came back to us so now
I'm thinking well thank God that we
stuck to our guns and didn't go up and
up and over get wrapped up in a bidding
war it's not even a house it's actually
a castle and right now I'm standing in
the garden with tennis courts and eight
acres of land and at the moment it's 12
or 13 flats we're gonna break it up into
18 apartments and one house and we find
that set and we'll hopefully fingers
crossed be able to pull out 1.2 million
profit in cash as well as having the
property to them rent out and we shall
be owning a passive income of around
about ten to twelve thousand pounds per
month from the deal so no money down
1.2 million profit ten thousand twelve
thousand pounds a month passive income
and it's just going to be a really
exciting project over the next year or
so doing it up and it's got so much
history absolutely beautiful so this is
this is a very big deal so right now I'm
feeling very very happy
[Music]
what did you think of the castle did you
like it because you're a princess aren't
you I bought this before ever seeing it
so even though I'm absolutely in love
with it this is not about feelings this
is still about profit so all of its all
got a bit business the purpose of a
business has got to be to make money and
so many people that they get involved in
projects just because they think oh it's
exciting or I love this or I can see so
much potential but they don't think
about the money but the cool thing is
about this is not only is it beautiful
and only are we in love with the
building but actually it's gonna make us
an awful lot of profit assuming it all
comes off so we've just walked up to the
church which is 30 seconds away from the
castle and it's open it's beautiful so
they might come back on Sunday to give
thanks for our blessings forced it
happened and also pray for a bit outcome
so if you want to see the developments
of this over the next 12-18 months and
keeping an eye on how much profit we're
making and the pros and cons and
pitfalls of development but also how
much money can be made then subscribe
below I'm going to be documenting the
journey and really look forward to it
hopefully it'll be a real real success
I'm still stepping out of my own comfort
zone right now I'm in buying a castle
with 8 acres of land around it and
splitting up into loads of flats I mean
there's Japanese knotweed everywhere
there's a roof that's falling down I'm
at my comfort zone but unless you're
growing and stepping out of your comfort
zone then you're dying
so like this building looks like it's
going I'd rather it be the building for
me
[Music]
thank you so much for watching if you
benefited on that video please do share
it with your family and friends for more
videos like it you can watch right here
and if you'd like to spend two days with
me at the property investors crash
course watch this video see what happens
but whatever you do don't forget to
subscribe right here and I'll see you
next time